is like the the test of I guess for
people in the industry of who knows
Roger obviously you would know Roger I
know Roger I've made two movies with him
I love him amazing cinematographer I'm
actually gonna go off on a tangent and
say I don't remember what films you did
with Roger which is it I'm putting
myself in trouble but what were the two
unit I did a beautiful mind of course I
did a house ascending fog I didn't know
he shot House of Sand and Fog but that
explains a little bit about that movie
yeah that I hadn't put together it's
been many years since I've worked with
him but he's extraordinary yeah actually
if you don't mind what is it do you if
you remember what was it about because
his work is brilliant he's like the god
do you remember what it was that just
really struck you about working with him
he's incredible composition he's able to
have a balance of composition but also
give actors space to move so he's able
to choreograph really precise shots
without making you feel like you're in a
box if that makes any sense like I never
felt like I was yeah I never I never
felt like I needed to be conscious of
where the camera was somehow I wherever
I was was sort of the right place
completely the thing I this is off on a
tangent but the thing that I found
fascinating was that he he told me that
he and some of the other directors like
Denis told me that he only shoots with
one doesn't do coverage it's just the
shot that he does and that's it
and yeah yeah it's crazy but let's
switch subjects completely do why I get
to talk to you I love this movie I wait
I am so in on this
what was it I would imagine you get
offered a lot of scripts what was it
about this one that said I want to do
this
I liked the world I liked the design I
thought that there's no one better to
bring it to life than James Cameron and
his team and Robert Rodriguez I thought
it was I was really excited to see what
they were gonna do with it and I liked
the idea of this character this young
girl at the center of this world sort of
shaking things up and making change well
I would imagine they're telling you when
you're getting the script to this
they're telling you what they're going
to do but there's an element of like you
got to use your imagination
and just kind of think to yourself what
it's really gonna look like yes and
there I saw renderings as our drawings
it's an artwork but yes it's a very
different thing something like the motor
ball sequences which were described to
me it's a very different thing seeing
them you know completely did you see did
you see it for the first time last night
or you know I saw it about a week
something like a week ago so it's not
for the first time what is that like
because you're obviously tremendously
using your imagination on set and you're
just thinking what is it going to look
like but yeah visuals are insane they're
insane my husband and I saw it together
and we kept looking at each other and
like tapping each other and shoulder go
like literally like oh my jaw was
hanging open and the first time you see
Aleta it's just I mean I couldn't
believe it
you know it's just so sophisticated now
it's so advanced and it's it's just so
beautifully done and it's amazing that
that character can integrate with real
elements like an orange or another actor
or a physical set and you believe it you
know
and it works you know at this point
because there was a time when I think
that there were earlier experiments with
that in other films that I've seen that
weren't as successful and this I feel
like it's finally it's clicked here yeah
the other thing is that I'm not the
biggest fan of 3d but the 3d and this is
exceptionally insane and you don't get
any of that funny and like Oh things are
a little wonky and it kind of works but
it doesn't it just it works and it's you
know the film was made to be 3d so it's
not like it's a regular movie and then
you have like one scene where all of a
sudden something's reaching for you you
know feels like it was designed to be it
there yeah it was it's not one of those
3ds that's trying to poke at you it's 3d
to add depth to the to everything yes
you know um one of the things I love
about the film is just the world it's
just it's fully realized and it's like
the mix of practical sets mixed with
these huge V effect it's you know what I
mean the way you sort of talk about the
world of Alita and just being on like a
practical set
it was really nice it was Robert built
that whole set that whole city really in
where his studio is in Texas and you
could wander around and it was very
fully realized you could walk into a
shop and it was dressed with tables and
you know it was decorated and and it was
pretty vast I mean you could have a
proper wander through the streets and
that was great so that was beautiful you
know that that artistry is also
beautiful is nice it's sort of both
these kinds of artistry were embraced
and employed in this way in the movie I
would imagine you had some cool outfits
and I would imagine you've uh you've
done a lot of movies have you ever
borrowed anything from set with every
intention of bringing it back I don't
think so no no really I I'm trying to
think I don't think so I'm kind of a
compulsive confessor Oh truth you know
like I'll say like oh I really like this
can I keep it but I wouldn't just thieve
something and put it my bagon and
pretend I didn't have it all right it's
not in me yeah I understand we're gonna
have to work on that I got to switch
subjects completely because I would
imagine you grew up loving Top Gun and
and Tom Cruise what the hell is it like
because I've seen pictures of you riding
the motorcycle with Paul and I'm like
really fast is that like who's again I'm
sure you grew up loving that movie like
all of us yeah sure it's amazing you
know it's so fun so fun to be part of
and you know how extraordinary that you
know what he's done in his career and
the work that he's done and yeah I'm
really excited to be a part of it we're
still working on it I was gonna say I
heard you shoot to like April or
something yeah we'll still be shooting
through April right I have to ask Tom is
known for pushing boundaries and
everything he does I would imagine he's
in a jet plane in this are you guys
going I'm just gonna make a joke but are
you guys
right um I will leave it alone then and
say my last thing for you you're also
doing snoop yourself yes I just wrapped
that right so what can you tease people
about that uh it was great it was really
nice it was a really interesting
experience for me I'm doing a whole
season of a television show I really
enjoyed the process I really like the
kind of work it was the sets are amazing
they're so cool it's so beautiful the
design of the world is really beautiful
the cast is great I loved working with
Graham our showrunner and it was a
really nice experience okay good I think
it's gonna look really cool can't wait
thank you so much angry rats on this
you